you've seen toys come to life in Toy
Story houses Claire
now kick your children's paranoia and to
overdrive with the exact same premise
but for video games wreck-it Ralph
travel to a fantasy world where video
game characters interact with each other
and an even bigger fantasy where kids
leave the house for some place called an
arcade arcadi
instead of yelling racial slurs at each
other on Xbox Live in this charming
dystopia we're living feeling game
characters spend their lives trapped in
an endless cycle of violence hikes now I
feel really bad for the guys inside Dark
Souls get ready for all your dad / older
brothers favorite gaming franchises to
join forces on the big screen in
teeny-tiny cameos and extremely subtle
references while you spend most of your
time with weird hybrid characters
because Disney couldn't get the rights
to Donkey Kong Master Chief or Mario but
they had plenty left in the budget for
Hubert and
hang on a second you had the rice to
Sonic the Hedgehog and you make tapper a
main character meet sarah silverman an
incorrigible PG version of sarah
silverman beauty who is secretly a
princess because Disney can't beer too
far off brand she'll raced on the path
of self-acceptance with the help of
Rekha drow a bad guy who's tired of
being bad I don't want to be the bad guy
anymore who runs away to become a good
guy I could be a good guy if I wanted to
which is bad for these good guys but
when our good bad guy realizes being bad
is good if he's bad for good reasons he
can say the good guys from the real bad
guy by being good at being bad it's not
as bad as it sounds when fate brings
these two misfits together they'll
journey across an arcade full of
possible game worlds yet only spend time
in two of a Kiros 2d a two dollar a pop
shooter on Rails that's over in like 30
seconds and sugar rush a candy coated
Mario Kart with so many candy puns
you'll swear the first draft was for a
Candyland movie nope there Laffy Taffy
who are you the guy that makes the
donuts call up the devil dogs the candy
corn videogames so revisit this adorable
animated adventure that finally cracked
how to make a good video game movie by
not focusing too much on the video games
and just like Toy Story uses bright
colors and fast pacing to distract you
from its horrifying existential
questions like if everyone lives in the
surge protector what happens if it gets
turned off what if they plug something
else in with the game's be able to go
into a microwave
are there different routes in different
arcades what if an arcade has to fix it
Felix games are they all going through
the same midlife crisis your game
programmers know what they're doing to
their creations
she's program with the most tragic
backstory ever isn't it dark that every
game character is terrified of breaking
the status quo must it bring instant
death from an uncaring god will be put
out of all of her car
and what the hell video game is Skrillex
from starry Kong see Riley Sarah
Sugarman repairman madman gamer gates
worst nightmare and for the love of God
don't go Oh sonic Bernard pixels if
Ralph really wanted to get things done
he should have just brought Kato along
Kato wins
be sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers push me
and then just touch me til I can get my
satisfaction satisfaction I will destroy
all snowballs and Twinkies will dominate
Jar Jar Binks is the best Star Wars no
no I refuse is this Tony stank I have a
turbo boner
I am mr. puppy pads stop asking me to
say things you imbeciles